Jero
whatever you think of mike huckabee's
politics you have to admit that he's a
brave man because he knew that the wiki
announced he was running I'd be showing
this photo of his family and you know
why they look so happy cuz they just ate
Mitt Romney's family euro the Chinese
zookeeper who had who licked a
constipated leaf monkeys anus for a full
hour so the monkey could pass a peanut
it had swallowed whole has to show us
the peanut I'm not saying you plotted
your whole career as a cover story so
you could lick a monkey's ass I am only
saying we'd all feel a hell of a lot
better if we saw the Pina
new rule a boxing match
has to have more punches landed than an
episode of Real Housewives
god I went hoarse from yelling hit him
hit him and that was just when Justin
Bieber walked in just from that narrow
the three Californians who were just
arrested for running a fake Masonic
Police Force which they claim is their
right based on their Knights Templar
bloodlines dating back to 1100 BC must
answer what one question what the [ __ ]
you know I don't know what's happening
here but whatever it is knock it off
this is a six year old child in China
but the love of God let him get back to
doing what six-year-old Chinese children
are supposed to be doing making my
iPhone